菲姐好像斯佳丽绿色的裙子，
发型也一样，
哎呀，
这话简直是说到菲菲姐的新巴上了，
虽然我知道你说这话纯属是为了讨我开心，
但是我也真的很开心，
我真的很受用，
女人就是这么简单啊，
就是一句话就夸就高兴了，
能高兴一整天，
我今天回去得跟我对象说，
你这样一天影该怎么夸我的吗？
就姐妹们，
你们要从龙菲姐身上捕捉一些让我生活变得幸福的特质，
就是哪怕孩子夸你一句啊，
哪怕邻居夸你一句，
你自己能高兴一天，
这日子就好过一点，
没人夸怎么办？
自己夸自己，
真的自己哄自己。
昨天的所有的姐妹们啊，
我是真的认真的跟大家讲，
你每天一定要去用心的打扮自己，
要用心的去穿好看的衣服，
用心的去做好看的发型，
用心的去化妆，
用心的去护肤，
用心的去打扮自己，
为什么？
因为你真的你打扮了之后，
你自己看到自己会心情好，
他是不一样的那种氛围，
整个生命状态不一样，
明白吗？
啊，
一定当你心情不好的时候，
感情不顺的时候，
事业不顺的时候，
啥事儿也不好的时候，
你一定要先从打扮自己开始，
可以换个发色，
可以换个指甲的颜色，
可以换个发型，
可以换个穿衣的造型，
可以换个护肤品，
可以干嘛干嘛的，
一定要去用心的去打扮你自己，
答应我好吗？
答应我的姐妹扣1，
因为你真的把自己打。
干的干干净净的啊，
白白净净的就是利利索索的，
穿着衣服鲜鲜亮亮的，
你会心情好，
你心情好，
一切才能变好，
你涂个口红，
你整张脸的肤色变亮了，
你心情就会不一样。
刚刚有个姐姐说她50岁了，
天天都把自己打扮的漂漂亮亮的，
特别好啊姐姐啊，
千万不要有美丽羞耻症啊，
我们不一定要打扮的那种花枝招展，
明艳动人，
不需要，
你只要把自己打扮的干干净净，
利利索索，
清清爽爽就很好。
记得点赞关注哦。